You now have an overview of how standards have evolved over
the years in terms of their structure, purpose and technology.
You should think about the difference between simpler classifications such as NDC,
CPT and ICD prior to version 10 and a complex ontology such as SNOMAD.
The standards community has struggled over the tension between perfection,
a standard that can represent medicine all of its detail and practicality,
standards that can actually be deployed and used in the real world.
This dichotomy extends equally to the topic of our next lesson,
interoperability standards, and it eventually lead to fire,
the subject of the following lesson.